[Music]
you know it's been nearly two years
since gwen stefani and blake shelton
started dating so what's the deal have
they begun to discuss a next step we've
got new information
they talk like they are going to be
together forever that's what a source
close to blake tells us about the couple
that will celebrate two years together
in october we're told quote they don't
talk about getting married but they are
very committed to one another and their
life together
[Music]
as for the kids well they love blake too
during summer vacay we saw blake jumping
into a lake with kingston and here he's
messing around with three-year-old
apollo the boys quote think blake is
really cool and he's made such an effort
to relate to them
they're so used to me hanging around
it's just blake to them so that's good
though it's incredible to have um a best
friend like that guy he's an amazing
person
and they've been together for so long
now in the beginning i never would have
put them together but i love them
together me too opposite the track
[Music]